Chase says Kurt have you considered your
inability to leave your mind and attend
to the things around you that is less of
a left brain issue and perhaps an issue
to be fleshed out in in therapy and
psychoanalysis
do you reckon this is just your nature
I am able to leave my mind
now occasionally it happens it's rare it
happens more often
more and more often
willfully
and
sometimes even without will then well
I'm considering many options Tiffany
says Tiffany Curley says do we require a
new religion to get us through the
current storm
or perhaps Tiffany and a new look at
existing religion Moses says my question
and this is a profound one why do you
have the same voice as Tom Cruise
now that's a first Moses
Kurt on the AMA can you do a little
digging on Google about creating a Time
Crystal
a new phase of matter has been
discovered in Newton's second law is now
destroyed compelling and so on
I I haven't looked into that I tend to
not look into what's in the news
scientifically like scientific America
because there are
on a weekly basis some
announcements about a large physical
breakthrough or some new measurement of
some mass of some particle and it breaks
all the laws and then
when one looks into the result or the
result's been replicated if with more
accuracy the discrepancy goes away
because of this I don't pay much
attention to what's occurring and I have
plenty on my plate already there are
plenty of
puzzles with the existing paradigms